[Music]
all right Aaron pay attention because
I'm going to have you introduce the
second episode citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch Invincible
season dose today if you didn't catch
our reactions for season one that I did
with Aaron Alexander over here they're
up here on the channel as well as our
reaction to Invincible Adam Eve special
I'm excited I did a rewatch over the
past couple of weeks so that way I could
remember the name Mark Grayson everyone
else's name that's washed over my brain
ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
be polite and ask Aaron how he's doing
so he feels included in the video Aaron
how are you doing I'm doing great baby
killing the intros I am killing the
intro that's what I love to hear is a
compliment about me that's why I asked
you a question leave a like on this
video people that would mean the world
to m w also subscribe click the
notification Bell cuz you best bet we're
going to be covering all this this is a
fantastic show thank you to prepper to
help us edit down these highlights as
always full length and watch along the
three sync up with your own copy of
invincible that is avail able for our
super sex rejects over at our patreon
page also we cover several shows over
there exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included
let's see what season 2 is all about man
I'm excited let's
[Music]
go oh the wait is
over oh damn okay he really is Immortal
this guy this man cannot die I've been
hit harder before like way harder so
arrogant just like your father yeah
maybe are they just training or does he
not trust Mark yeah feel like they're
training yeah he not going for any death
blows or
anything yeah he has to be cuz this is
the closest thing he has to fighting
someone like his dad and they have to
prepare for the uh the Army that's
coming back why can't you trou me oh
after what omn man did after what you
did oh maybe this is a dream this is a
dream kill him for the third time on me
man awesome God
damn nightmare was a nightmare The
Immortal lived for thousands of years
trying to make this planet better for
all its people but did not succeed
thought he'd see the truth like you did
how there's still brains on his head
yeah we know you all feel like we're the
bad guys because my dad and I took over
your planet this a long dream you're
going to be part of the filtrum Empire
now he's torn between paths the more you
resist the worse this gets we didn't
didn't destroy your cities you destroyed
them by fighting
back way to blame join us in welcoming
them and if you still think you can stop
us don't forget I'm
invincible people I just plays on repeat
I don't think it's a dream maybe it's
like a Multiverse situation I was just
thinking that yeah alterate Universe
kind of thing no one dies from cancer
and no one ever messes with Earth again
ooh Secret group fighting against the
enemy angstrom were you followed the
immortal LED them away we're safe yeah
that's what Rex thought too yeah
Multiverse oh that's
hot did you retrieve the null energy
Sarah Conor [__] if this doesn't make
omim man have a bad day nothing will the
null
energy T versy guy
[Music]
oh
wa it's cool that you get to see Mark go
down this dark path in this version yeah
[Music]
right no he can't feel
it oh wow
fascinating more destruction at a train
station
someday you too will
die a but you should have died at Birth
damn so
mean she looks like neas on a teenage
teenage Warhead with that the whole fit
from from Deadpool one you and your
stupid resistance made us kill thousands
of innocent people you made us you made
us your
fault stop this or I stop you please I'd
rather die
I love the manipulation conversation I
would never kill you but I can't let you
hurt anyone
else no he's going to disable
her you just lied you just lied she
didn't leave you a choice well no he
justified just paralyzed oh she's
paralyzed yeah that's better so that's
what you were practicing on those
protesters last week I couldn't figure
it
out so Sinister say how casual he is
about it it's just so disturbing hey
buddy you sentenced yourself to death
when you joined Club resistance justice
justice will come for you that's
Sterling K Brown oh yep I hear it y
wheree Multiverse let's finish this off
I'm
starving Purge I'm on I'm on team evil
amican omn man side how a goat clearly
they know what they're talking about I'd
rather be on The Winning
Side why would you not want to be come
on D the blood D up blood is still there
Perma blood Mark left a
mark that a villain in the water oh
that's smart or was he using it yeah
he's using it okay I was able to
generate enough speed to do
it
it's like a elephant man yeah it's like
a take on
Rhino I love this like melancholic
Montage of being a hero they they
utilize their music well like he's just
doing his duty but there's lack of
emotion behind it
yeah the actions coupled with the song
Make Me Think like what he's doing right
now is like his pentant like he's like
he has to make up for all the damage he
caused yep yeah exactly
yeah no I mean Mark's traumatized of
course yeah his dad is like a
monster a you don't have to go back if
you're not ready neither do you the
amount of pain that must be omitted from
this these two
yeah see you later mom you too what real
EST day why don't you
move well kill the Iguana
do it
already we've got security turned up to
100 on YouTube new cameras new guns new
doors that won't stop them you ain't
gone nowhere yeah they are immediately I
[__] portals now didn't I mention that
see you around
Pete poor Pete probably so fright for
his
life guys keep going in and out of Ja
the hell are we I bet he
knows pepep sterling sterling knows
maybe they need the scientist mind of
them what happened here a tragedy this
isn't your world my name is angstrom ly
that must be a big character from the
comics or
something a Multiverse traveler I
imagine he would be working with the two
of you is a real ethical and moral
stretch for me but I don't have a choice
there's no one else with your scientific
Gena I don't know there's something that
seems deceitful about you
man do they all know Mark
Grayson be friendly listen I or cuz I
think Nolan sorry your dad got exploded
yeah that's
right died right but I don't really want
to that sucks man totally sucks talk
about
it I hear your dad was an okay guy
though and he was was like Jack right I
bet you wish you got those je and now he
has to live alive during his grief yeah
but I don't get to be sad I'm part of
the problem I'm the reason all those
people in Chicago Died that's not true
wait a second I I shouldn't be here I
should be out there classic Hero's guilt
you didn't kill those people Mark omn
man did but I didn't save them you
stopped your dad and saved the planet
you didn't really stop him you don't owe
anyone anything that's so sure I don't
think Sten young gets enough credit for
how great of a voice job he does here
yeah man he's just a great overall actor
I need to be out there you need to start
calling on me again hold on I'm better
I'm stronger I'm ready no you're not
could be worried about his Darkness you
think I haven't been watching your early
morning outings that's why I need you
it's only been a month Mark focus on
your mom your grades damn that passage
of time is short yeah the newscaster
said it's only been a few weeks in
Chicago you saved a ton of them but you
also went through an emotional tumble
dryer and I need to know your head stop
spinning before I let you back in the
game so no he can make a callous
decision I don't need your permission to
be a superhero you're not my dad you
know who else said that to me I'm not my
dad that's why omn man never joined I'm
not my
dad that's that darkness that he's
worried about you're not my dad and I'm
not my dad I mean what a tough grieving
position you feel like you got to take
some level of control this thing still
going on it's not going well hey it's
Bobby the guardian could use some help
Invincible I'm not making the same
mistake I made with no one I thought he
died maybe he's a clone
yeah om man killed him what the hell he
was a clone based on his speech patterns
in vocabulary the giant seems to have
the mental capacity of an
8-year-old an 8-year-old
what so is robot in the suit or is he
piling it remotely piling it remotely
through his mind maybe we can buy him
some Comics or something a damn I don't
care how oh black Samson he needs to go
down now that's an excellent suggestion
Samson there's a multi-level parking
garage beneath this intersection I will
detonate stress points in the concrete
and drop the giant into it I love how
they're working so much like a team
now come on why are you so me
me what happened I don't no I couldn't
move oh I guess he is Su in the suit my
heart was racing I was all sweaty that's
fear before all this was just a video
game for you now you're here in person
playing for real oh [__] like an armored
suit situation yeah an Iron Man why him
discovering a new version of humanity I
would have just done neural link why not
you doing that before would just keep
doing that that's one of our sematic
encoders but bigger I based it off your
design it reads copies and writes human
Minds design of our Earth or their Earth
what do you need it for what's in it for
us instead let me appeal to your
philanthropic nature go on I don't trust
him I don't trust him there's an
infinite number of dimensions and I was
born with the ability to access all of
them why does he say in this Dimension
though remember that world changing
battle between omn man and Invincible a
month ago in most other dimensions they
teamed up and took over the planet oh
all our problems famine War climate
change there's a solution out there have
been solved somewhere else and I can be
the conduit of that knowledge a
Prometheus who raises the bar for
Everyone by sharing what works he got a
God complex a lot of power to do this I
need deep knowledge of those other
dimensions good thing we've always been
inquisitive we've always
been so he is friends with them all that
meet the
family wow he's self-absorbed
he's like a king he's like a king meets
America
Chavez they don't have my ability but
they have something almost as valuable
oh intimate local knowledge of their
home Dimensions that will help me figure
out what they do best and how to get it
here but you still want to be the
dominant one don't you of course help me
do this and I'll give you any single
Dimension you want as long as you
promise not to hurt anyone oh you are
developing a villain we want one with no
superheroes good food and a population
that thinks we're
Gods he's the one from the that we were
watching earlier who lost in the that
one we just cut to right there oh Eve
got paralyzed you were hurt as badly as
I was both our husbands died that night
you can be sad and angry at the same
time that's grief for you Nolan killed
so many people he almost killed Mark 20
years and I was a goddamn
pet this feels so much more human I like
yeah like we can sit in the drama of it
I have to go back to Moscow in a few
days but uh what's this this something
that helped me medical marijuana it's
good to see you mark uh I'm going to go
to my room Olam made dinner part8 just
the sadness permeates through all this
I'm glad they took this direction makes
most sense last 15 engagements and
narrowed it down to a failure of
leadership it was the prom last season
I'm still adjusting to my new body and
I'm instituting a
change oh damn it's also obvious the
team needs more muscle meat bulletproof
bulletproof hey oh God damn re explode
you think of that grade school [__]
yourself or did somebody help you with
that I I mean bulletproof isn't that
great I know you tyght be better I I was
trying to be better was
new training schedules are in your
lockers first session is in 30 minutes
dismissed I can't quite pinpoint the
animation but there's just something
that feels more refined about it my
leadership has been suboptimal and
that's a problem and like any problem it
needs to be fixed there are Great
Character setups here they're also a
natural continuation of last season when
I was a kid I always wanted to be my dad
what if that happens what if I become
him and I don't even know it that is the
horror you have to face it's a real fear
yeah you're not your dad Mark the whole
world knows that Cecil doesn't so prove
him wrong there's more detail to the
facial expressions too there's a lot I
like a more about the way it looks Mark
it's not a good I'll work for you I'll
follow orders I'll let you make all the
calls put me back out there energy
levels just went off the chart I wonder
how that'll work out for Mark someone
get this kid an earpiece what happens
when Mark doesn't like the order that's
an inevitable
problem we'll probably face also Mark
has to find out that most of the other
versions of him joined his dad yeah it's
really going to mess with them open your
portals and we'll connect to the other
nine
machines transdimensional interconnects
are stable 1,000 Minds synchronized how
can your brain handle then once we start
the process it's impossible to stop at
these power levels severe brain damage
would be the the least of your problems
oh yeah that's probably going to push
him over the edge getting all that
information
overload I am
large I contain
multitude oh my God that's not good spit
it out kid okay there's like a giant
mechanical Christmas tree with like a
bunch of the same
guys
ah wait Invincible you don't understand
he's definitely not Invincible stop this
is for the greater good that's what all
villains
say oh all the M twins you were using
other uses you said we were
[Music]
special that's what they all
say
this is the first time Invincible ever
encountered them huh I was just thinking
that yeah yes
woof stop him but don't kill him oh
we're going to do
both get up man oh I was going to use
that Rage that's enough I said stop Vite
rage we're almost done why doesn't he
want Invincible that they might maybe he
is good I don't know I won't build my
Utopia with
blood oh he has ethics I was going to
take it off going to mess him up is good
maybe taking it off too early is going
to mess him
up that's I thought God damn killed the
mullers killed all of them at least a
fraction of them what I did not call it
I thought he was going to go down a
really I thought he was for sure bad I
think he still could be sure he said he
would have build it a with blood man
like he refused to let Invincible die in
that moment just cuz he's has a code of
ethics doesn't mean he's not bad no no
no not
again uh the guilt look I I don't know
what they were up to but I'd say you
stopped it pretty in
spectacularly and even the MERS didn't
deserve this everyone here did this to
themselves and whatever they were
planning you stopped them man this is so
tragic like there's never a real victory
for him anymore some male came for you
you first get into college no way you
first okay same time what is this no way
home on being accepted to Upstate
University Miss Bennett what do you
wanted to say say that we're going to
college together I don't believe you
quit being a [__]
[Music]
Amber I believe you now oh my God I got
in I got in hey
yay
he doesn't trust him I don't know if you
heard but I'm working for Cecil now so
you know if you needs some help or want
to team up just give me a Cecil thinks
you're on our side yeah I'm not so sure
Mark needs to be sure to I'll be
watching
you oh man what an episode one wow oh oh
I forgot about that I forgot they do
that the one from the other Universe
probably survived the one with the the
sweatshirt we
saw I told him not to take off the damn
helmet oh oh God oh God brother is that
you what the hell how are you even
[Music]
breathing oh no oh it's the one he had
the superb
brain the
no what did he do to me oh [__] oh wow
he did this it made me a
freak I ruined
everything he's going to be a villain
yeah you've lost track of what memories
are yours and which come from the others
they are all my memories you need a
hospital what the hell is a hospital
going to do I need Revenge I need need
to make him pay I won't rest until I've
G there it is a h
[Music]
oh oh oh I guess we're going to build to
the cracks now oh another one it's the
last time I work for anyone else ever
it's
not
wow wow what a great episode one it is
yeah
he's like um The Who's The Incredible
Hulk villain oh the leader the leader
yeah he's like the leader yeah yeah like
a multiversal leader wow man that was a
good episode they they looked sharp I
feel like their clothes looked
especially sharp this time around the
details on it yeah it's fresher in your
AR I'm seg
Wang reject Nation shop.com baby that's
what I'm talking about guys I want to
thank everyone who's been buying shirts
over at the real reject store we got
shirts like this one child protection
services here crossover between Pedro
Pascal lass us and of course grou from
Mandalorian show we also got other ones
like space babies of the Galaxy we got
who influences the influencers is
Watchman inspired we also got the
America's ass one as well that's my new
personal favorite one love that one we
got our soda shirt we got our snip shirt
we got the bat verse t-shirt we got a
whole bunch of other te's over there and
I really appreciate cuz we are
creatively involved with all them it's
been uh remarkable to see the level of
support it's it's honestly my favorite
way that people have been supporting the
channel simply because like yeah we get
to get involved creatively with it I
love seeing people rocking them and
wearing them and if you end up buying
one tag us on social media and we'll be
sure to add share a story of it and all
that jazz because we absolutely
appreciate it and love it and I love to
see when people are rocking them as well
any let's talk about this episode of
invincible my friend yeah we just saw a
villain origin story right now have me
going man it was real back and forth I
mean for the most part I was like gangho
he's a villainous and then he made a um
the Evelyn Choice there in the end he's
like I will not have this built on blood
and then it lands him in the blame
territory yeah just killed a lot of
people when it's like dude you made your
choice yeah he's got his head scrambled
because he was the one who made the
choice he was the one who said like I
will not like they could have let him
kill
Invincible yeah he's for him to blame
he's like no man you got all wrong but
it's all mixed up because maybe there
were other ones who were thinking
Invincible die I figured as soon as he
put that helmet on he's going to
download all of them like okay yeah he's
definitely going to be bad after this
but there's everyone with like different
thoughts and choices too who would have
probably preferred that Invincible died
yeah cuz most universes He's the bad guy
with exactly exactly but this guy knew
that this invincible was good oh man so
yeah he's that's clever yeah this
multiversal threat that now has
essentially like
schizophrenia that's
wild that's wild that's insane what I
love about what what the show Invincible
does it takes a lot of these whereas
like the boys is very much like
satirical and commentary on superhero
universes like Invincible still lives
and breeds the comic book world and the
tropes but makes it their own yeah and
does it in a way that's much more mature
and R-rated with a little bit of
commentary here or there of course um
but they you take it serious you know
yeah and I think that's what they've
done here too is like we've seen so much
Multiverse stuff and now we're going to
get like the R-rated version of a
Multiverse in the comic book medium
which I'm really excited about yeah yeah
I think this show does what I like about
comic books in the sense that it is this
larger than life kind of U experience
but they do have a lot of character
depth within their storytelling and I
feel like within most of the modern or
more mainstream comic book properties we
really just to barely scratch the
surface of what that means and like
those those deeper character themes and
I like the fact that we're the show
allows us to sit with those things
allows us to explore what what it means
to be a superhero what what it means to
live within that World um rather than
trying to you know get to the plot and
like kind of like okay we got to we got
to get through this we we got six
episodes or like oh we only got two
hours uh no let's just actually live
with those characters you know kind of
uh yeah explores in a meaningful way
which I appreciate and yeah no I I kind
of I kind of agree with everything
you're saying we're kind of commenting
throughout the whole episode the fact
that this really is an exploration of
where do we go next with Mark where do
we go next with this world how is the
world receiving what happened and how is
Mark taking that on and I think it's
it's a very smart and interesting choice
the fact that he internally wrestles
with who he is and his identity and
trying to prove that he's not the bad
guy even though the world and certain
people within his life may see him as
such and like the guilt that comes with
that and like it's that classic
superhero Thing of the weight of the
world on your shoulders but tackled in a
more meaningful way which I really
appreciated very meaningful it because
so much of like last season when Mark uh
you know dealt with him being told that
this is his Destiny you know he would
wait around for when his powers are
going to kick in because he's a vulture
might he's not just human and then after
become vulture might his whole identity
was as reestablished here he his whole
goal was to become his dad at least the
image of what his dad fostered here on
this planet like I want to become the
Savior worshiped him and then a month
ago that's all shattered now yeah and I
love what I love that they're doing is
they're leading with the Doom and Gloom
like the the Doom and Gloom looms over
everything here CU it extends far beyond
just Mark and his mom it's the the world
this was the world Superman this was the
world savior yeah and the world savior
is actually the world's greatest enemy
now and their their biggest threat like
it's it was the biggest Con in the world
and you feel like nothing is as safe as
it once was then you have Mark who is
still amateur uh hero there's he's
nowhere near the professional grade hero
that he needs to be at and the
threatening part of it is it makes him
susceptible to give into the darkness
not not that I ever think arm mark would
ever give into the darkness uh but I
like that they set up that in other
worlds he he does give into it that most
worlds he does succumb to thinking this
is the right way and I love the
portrayal of that because the portrayal
he do he genuinely is like it's such a
Draconian evil way of thinking of he's
not just like spouting mean lines he's
constantly like well you did this to
yourself yeah you're the reason you're
about to die like you made this choice
and you're not thinking about what's
actually really good so I have to
annihilate you it's Sinister and in a
way where there's no awareness of just
the the the amount of Cruelty you know
know it is it is pure evil dominance and
Mark being in the being thrusted in with
a different kind of Darkness from
feeling betrayed by his
dad I love that cil's because last
season ceso wanted him to work with him
and then to pick it up here is actually
a more human choice of being like you're
kind of in too dark of a place and that
leaves you in a way to be influenced by
Darkness a lot worse so I'm going to
I I kind of need to keep you at a
distance or I need to keep you under
control which is the only way Cecil
would have let him work for him is if
Cil can control him in some way right
you know um and not let him just be his
own free agent as well yeah they got
like a lot of Great Character setup too
which is really compelling and a lot of
complexity to it yeah I like the mom is
having a more prominent role in it as
well because we get to see her side of
things with her uh meeting with her
friend and like us allowing us to to sit
in that moment with her and to see where
where her story is going to go you know
cuz she had it was just as big of a loss
for her as it was for Mark like that was
her husband of 20 years and knowing
someone for 20 years and finding out
they viewed you as a pet not only they
viewed you as a pet but they're this
supremely evil being that wants to
destroy and take over the planet like
man that's that's that's a lot you know
and I hope we get to a point where we
get to see both Mark and her kind of
come together because
yeah grief can be a a very isolating
experience you know like they're both
trying to even though they both know the
other isn't okay they're both trying to
like keep it all together well they have
a shared trauma bond in a way you know
they have a shared tragedy together son
betrayed by a father and that father is
the Betrayed the wife yeah H so there is
there they them two only have each other
and they're the only ones who can sort
of understand and the mom has to
constantly um put up the this appearance
of strength and and capability you know
so I think there's a lot of and there's
other characters we haven't checked in
with like art and whatever I like the
development of um of our team like what
they set up with robot I think is great
uh of him having to better
understand because it was a human
controlling the robot machine and now he
is he has been reborn essentially and
now he's having to understand
fear in a different way like and how to
make choices like that as well which I
think is really compelling stuff because
in the last season when he when he did
get the body he did just keep it
neurally linked with stuff so I I just
assume that's what he would do again so
I'm I'm curious what the choice is to
actually be in the suit it feels so much
more dangerous yeah so um but there must
be a reasoning to at the same time it's
going to allow him to develop more as a
human human and even as whatever that
little like overgrown fetus looking
thing that he was before that he still
was like artificial in a way yeah you
know and and now he's going to really
find his Humanity I think like they've
they've really set up a good human
development with him even Rex Spode
seems a little more human than before
like he's not still douchy but not as
douchy yeah cuz he was cheating on uh
Kate the first season right right just
all ego and uh he's been a humbled yeah
yeah I'm curious to see where the other
characters go like we watched a whole
special with Alice Eve we really to
spend a lot of time with her this
episode Adam Adam Eve what did I say
Alice Eve yep that's that
actress but yeah Adam Eve I think that
uh yeah I'm curious to see where her
head is at you know CU we only got
really that one scene with her and Mark
uh towards like the the middle-ish end
we didn't even check in with Mark's
friend yeah yeah we didn't no this this
is William his name yeah William I think
so yeah there's a yeah this show has a
big cast and obviously invincible and
marker the lead of that show and of this
cast but yeah I think the the show's
done a great job of of having a great
Ensemble of of interesting fleshed out
well well-written characters and yeah
just makes you curious to see where all
these things go because this is kind of
as you said before the uh natural
continuation of this journey that we've
kind of started with the first season
and yeah I think there's I don't know
there a lot of potential for a really
interesting story to uh to come out of
that I'm pretty sure that they kept us
really focused yeah and Mel and kept
molic yeah because they could have cut
around to like every character and they
just cut they didn't cut around to a lot
of other characters they kept it really
focused on the on the soul of this story
yeah CU what happened was really heavy
yeah and there's like nothing but
Darkness for Mark like like everything
kind of just feels like a loss in some
way mhm you know H even when he has a
victory it doesn't really truly feel
like nothing truly feels Victorious for
the guy uh I think it's great I thought
I thought this was a really solid P like
I know like the last couple of episodes
of season 1 were super exciting and
super intense and maybe they thought
they we go like full steam ahead um but
I really like this direction of the
first episode a lot yeah we needed to
come back down because you know we had
this extreme high and now we're in the
the aftermath of that like it's only
been a few weeks to a month within its
world so we need to see like where
everybody's at you know it's primarily
mark my my question as of right now
obviously we're going to continue
watching so we find out what happens but
wasn't was that a post credit scene the
fact that um Seth Rogan's character said
like we need to start preparing because
the VMS are coming yeah yeah no that
what uh that was the ending or the post
credit I forget which one of of last
season but like is that information or
that something that's happened as of yet
because I think at the end of that's
definitely happened yeah did they I
don't they referenced it in the episod
they did not reference it in this
episode um which oh you're saying like
maybe that was a scene that happens
later on in the story we're going to
find out that some of this is actually
happening before the interaction exactly
maybe perhaps um I don't think so CU I
feel like that's like an immediate
threat like oh yeah that's that's what I
mean is what I thought we were going to
go like pedal to the metal we need to
like get our alliance ready for when omn
man returns exactly U or the vulture
mites return because they're going to
try to dominate so that's why I think
the Multiverse thing is is a
fascinating fascinating thing to infuse
in here because there's like a couple of
ways you can go about it you can have
um you can form a greater Alliance to
protect your Earth whatever our Earth is
called or you can make the Threat Level
worse because you got other invincibles
and omn man out there you know so I I
don't know which area it's going to go
down but I I really feel like we haven't
seen anything yet oh no yeah cuz we just
started this plot with the the
Multiverse and our new seemingly
antagonist and but I want to just get
back to omn man you know I don't really
I like I like the setup of what the door
it's opening but I'm like ah just get
back on yeah I mean I'm it definitely
has me curious for sure like how this is
going to connect to the other stuff and
I wonder if we're going to put the omn
man stuff on the back burner to address
this multiversal thing right now or if
these are going to these two things are
going to correlate and uh come together
to kind of stop this this end or like
this uh threat that's coming sure yeah I
get what you're saying I get what you're
getting um but yeah overall um really
loved it uh a lot uh different than I
expected it to be but I did appreciate
the focus of it a lot I thought that was
great I thought that was really great
seriously yeah um what did you guys
think did you like the first episode
leave your thoughts down below thank you
guys for joining us uh you can be sure
to subscribe leave a like click that
Bell All That Jazz and uh we'll catch
you all soon peace out reack Nation
[Music]